字幕: UDO Rina
校正: Emi Atarashi
皆さん これ
何だかわかりますか
そう キクラゲです
キノコの仲間なんですよね
12歳の時 たまたま
キクラゲの話になりました
確か 苦手な食べ物とか
そんな
たわいもない話だったと思います
友達が言ってたんです
「俺 キクラゲあかんわ
キクラゲって あのコリコリする
クラゲの仲間やんな」
「んん？」
僕は突っ込みました
「キクラゲは キノコの一種やと思うで」
ところが 声の大きなK君が来て
一喝するんです
(K君)「アホか キクラゲはクラゲやで
中華料理とかに入っとるやろ」
「いや 中華料理のクラゲとは違うやつや
キクラゲは キノコやで」
(K君)「クラゲやと思う人」
「はい はい はーい」
６人のうちですね ４人がクラゲと答え
多数決の結果
キクラゲは
クラゲとされてしまったんです
（笑）
なんで多数決で決めんねん
とふてくされる僕に
「アホ 民主主義は多数決なんや」と
K君は言い放ちました
キクラゲをクラゲと断定され
腹も立ちましたが
今まで あんまり考えたこともなかった
「民主主義」が 心にひっかかりました
「民主主義？
みんなで決めるっていう
意味やんな
多数決で決めるっていう
意味なんかな？
しかし 声の大きいやつは
有利やなあ
正しいことを言っても
声が小さいと聞いてもらわれへん
それが伝えられる地位にならんと
あかんのや」と
12歳の僕は
思ってしまったんですね
その後 僕は
「将来は政治家になろう」と
思うようになりました
うーん
手段と目的を 取り違えてます
心配ですね
ともあれ 12歳の僕は
勉強を始めました
さて大学に入り
19歳の僕
政治の授業を
受けてたんですね
先生に「政治家になりたいんです」
と伝えました
すると
「君ね 勉強してたら政治家になれる
と思ったら大間違いだよ
政治家になるには まず
先生のカバン持ちを何年もやらないと
お父さんが政治家だ
っていうような地盤とか
有名人としての看板があれば
別だけどね
選挙に勝つには
お金だってすごくかかる
地盤、看板、カバン って
言うだろう？」
ガーン
政治家になるって
そういうことなんだろうか
僕は がっかりして
もやもやして 過ごしていました
でも 落ち込んでいる僕を
元気づける出会いもありました
それは インターネットでした
キーワードを入力するだけで
好きなバンドのツアーの
スケジュールから
アメリカ政府の発表資料まで
読めるんです
こいつは すごいぞ
当時は まだ ネット検索を知ってる人が
あまりいなかったんです
だから 僕は
「あいつに聞けばなんでもわかる」と
一時期 言われていたんですね
実際は 裏で
検索してただけなんですけど
幸いなことに 大学では
「インターネットを作った父」と言われる
村井純先生の思想にも
触れることができました
インターネットには
中央がない
だから どこかが壊れても
どこかが補完していく
あらゆる地域が あらゆる産業が
あらゆる人が
等しくつながることができる
これがインターネットなんだ
これはきっと新しい時代になる
僕は確信しました
情報で世界が繋がるのであれば
政治家にならなくったって
社会を変えられるかも
インターネットに夢中になるうち
僕は 政治家を目指そうという気持ちは
なくなっていきました
23歳の時
僕はIT企業に就職します
大きな企業の情報システムに触れて
ITが現場でどういう風に使われるのか
学んでいきました
そんな社会人生活を送る中で
ウィキペディアが出てきたんですね
当時はまだ 今ほどの情報量は
なかったんですけれど
みんなで作る
世界の無料のオンラインの辞書
これに興奮しました
村井先生が言っていた
「中央」がなくて
どこかが壊れても誰かが補完していく
っていうインターネットの特性を
ウィキペディアは ずばりと
見せ付けてくれたんです
情報が多くの人に開かれていく
人間ってすごい
オープンってすごい
この素晴らしさを
もっともっと活用するには
どうしたらいいんだろう
こんな思いで会社に勤めながら
社会人大学院にも入学したんです
そこで 僕が IT関連の授業と思って
勘違いで履修した 未来学っていう
授業がありました
ここで論じられていたのが
気候変動問題だったんです
この時の衝撃が
僕のこの後の生き方を
変えるきっかけにもなりました
温度上昇がもたらす
熱波、洪水、水の枯渇
生態系が大きく崩れて
食べ物が不足して
太古のウイルスが地上に
出現してしまう
この状況を食い止めるために
科学者たちは
それこそ 僕が生まれる前から
温室効果ガスの排出を抑えるように
警告してきました
先進国の間で ようやく
京都議定書っていう
二酸化炭素を削減するルールができたんです
しかし 世界の足並みは
全く揃いませんでした
「先進国だけに義務があるなんて
アンフェアだ」とか
「経済は 一体どうするんだ」
自分たちが 将来
生きるか死ぬかの問題であったとしても
国家間の意思決定というのは
一筋縄ではいきません
僕も 一度目指していた
この中央集権の選ばれし者たちの会議は
物事を先送りにして
有効な手段が取られることのないままに
時間が過ぎ去っているんです
そして 多くの人たちにとっても
忙しい日常の中で
この問題への熱意は続きません
これは 現在までの
二酸化炭素の濃度と平均気温のグラフです
1979年に
国際気候会議があって以来
僕が幻滅した京都議定書、パリ協定など
いっぱい話し合いを
経ているんですけれども
一本調子に
状況が悪くなっているのが分かります
これが 残念ながら
国の代表たちが
話し合いを続けている結果なんです
これって キクラゲをクラゲだと決めた
キクラゲ民主主義と
本質的に 変わりませんよね
まったく多数決って
何なんでしょう
ここで少し 考えてみたいんです
実はこういう問題は
気候変動の話だけではありません
なんで 僕らは 集団になると
妥当な意思決定が
できなくなるんだろう
それは 決める立場にある人が
痛みを伴う決定をすると損をすると
近視眼的になっているからでは
ないでしょうか
多くの 決める立場を
人に任せている人たちは
どこかの誰かが
きっとうまくやってくれるはずと
思っているからかもしれません
どうやったら この状況を脱して
良い意思決定が
できるようになるのだろう
僕は大学院に通い始めた頃から
人間集団の意思決定を
より バージョンアップする方法はないのかと
考えるようになっていきました
村井純先生も言っていた
あらゆる人たちがつながり
壊れても 誰かが補完するっていう
インターネットの力を
意思決定に使えないのか
そんなことを
思うようになっていきました
この問題意識に応えてくれる技術が
このあと登場するんです
それは 自動翻訳技術です
2018年頃
翻訳技術の精度が
大きく向上したんです
とっても不自然だった翻訳が
ディープラーニング技術の登場で
とってもなめらかになり
日々 精度が進化してるんですね
アラビア語も ギリシャ語も
ヘブライ語も ベトナム語も
今まで全くたどり着くことのできなかった
様々な言語で書かれた文章が
母国語で読めるんです
僕は この翻訳技術を使えば
世界のあらゆる場所で行われる
意思決定にも
人々が触れることができるようになると
考えました
僕らの未来にとって重要な問題を
キクラゲ民主主義で
決めてしまわないためには
みんながそれをウォッチできるように
すればいいじゃないか
民主主義、インターネット、中央のない分散型
オープン、翻訳テクノロジー
僕の中で 色んなものが繋がりました
過去の人類ができなかったものでも
今ならできるかもしれない
2018年に 僕は
勤めていた会社を辞めて 起業しました
ルールが作られていくプロセスを
世界中の人に
見てもらえるようにしようと決めました
僕は「ルール」
ルールこそが
解決の鍵なんだと気づいたんです
でもルールは 僕たちを縛り
どこか一部の人が
得をするように設けられたもの
っていう印象を持つ人も
実は 圧倒的なんじゃないでしょうか
しかし よく考えてみてください
ルールは本来
僕たちの暮らしを良くするために
設計されるべきものであるんです
世界には解決の難しい問題が
いろいろあります
ルールは この問題に
立ち向かっていくための
僕らの武器でもあるんです
これが 僕が 今日
みなさんにお伝えしたかったこと
「みんなで作るルールは
世界の難問への武器になる」です
持続可能なイノベーションに
投資を向けるとか
配慮のない技術に 制限をかけるとか
草の根の活動に お金をまわすとか
これらは全て ルールによって
成り立っているんです
ルールで僕らは
ありたい社会をデザインできるんです
幼かった僕は
民主主義は多数決のことを
言い換えているんだと思っていました
しかし 今ならば
自信を持って言えます
民主主義とは
単なる多数決のことではありません
共に答えを作っていくプロセス
プロセスなんです
だから 多数決は そのプロセスの
最後の... 最後の手段であるだけなんです
このありたい社会を
デザインするプロセスに
多くの人が関わってほしい
気候変動のような 国境を越えてくる
人類全体に影響するような様々な問題にも
みんなで答えを作るんです
一部の声の大きな人たちだけの多数決は
本当の民主主義ではありません
そんなのは
キクラゲ民主主義なんです
多くの人が関わって
そこに分断を生まないで
世界中の知恵を集めて
磨いていける
こういう場が必要なんです
そう考えて 僕は
ルールウォッチャーを発明しました
翻訳技術を使って
色んな国のルールが
作られていくプロセスを
インターネット上に
見えるようにしたんです
ルールウォッチャーは
たくさんの人が集える
プラットフォームでもあります
インターネットが持つ
分散とオープンの思想で作りました
ルールウォッチャーには
現時点で
800以上の国連とか 政府
NGOなどの
ルール作りに関する発表を
行っている団体の情報が
毎日 自動的に集められてきます
僕らは 翻訳技術のおかげで
人類で初めて
他の国のルールができていく過程を
見られるんです
ウィキペディアのように
ルールを作っている時点で
声を上げることができるんです
ルールウォッチャーでは
自分の国のルールメイキングと
他の国のメイキングを
比較することができます
そして気候変動などの
国境を越えてくるような問題に対しても
同じ関心を持った人たちと
国を超えて繋がって 対話して
行動することができるんです
皆さん
世界には 活用されていない知恵が
膨大にあるはずです
これが 過去の人類には使えなかった
我々の世代の武器なんです
昔は 他の国が
どんなことをやっているか
勉強しようと思ったら
それこそ大変でした
今は ほとんど リアルタイムで
数クリックで 比較できるんです
これで 知の国境を破るんです
政治リーダーだけに任せられないのは
歴史を見ても明らかです
でも それは
政治リーダーのせいではなくて
民主主義のレベルが
足りなかったのかもしれない
教科書が言うところの
民主主義っていうのは
決して「為政者が民衆をコントロールする」
っていう意味ではありませんが
実際は こういうイメージです
自分の知らないところで
声の大きい人の意見でできた
ルールなんかに
本当は 誰も従いたくないですよね
でも 自分も関わってきたルールだったら
納得感が違う
だから 社会も動く
つまり ルールに関心を持つ人が
増えることで
ついに 本来の民主主義になり
気候変動のような
大きな問題の解決に近づくんです
そんな未来が もう
手の届くところまで来ているんです
僕らは テクノロジーの力を借りて
本当の民主主義に挑める
人類初の世代なんです
今だからできます
矢印の向きを 変えましょう
テクノロジーを使いこなして
国境を越えてくる世界の難問に
共に立ち向かうんです
皆さんも このムーブメントに加わり
民主主義の進化を
一緒に作っていきませんか
世界のルールを みんなの手で
ありがとうございました
（拍手）